now I hope you'll know at least this one
reminds you that if you are solving an
equation that's like a quadratic okay
you know there are how many solutions to
right namely x equals plus or minus five
good so you know when you're solving an
equation you get two solutions but if
you're asked to evaluate an expression
like 325 you know in fact there's only
one value right it's not two values for
root 25 there's only one okay X is only
equal sorry not X this number is only
five right it's not like Oh sometimes I
don't know it's only five and the reason
why this is confusing to students is
because it's actually language here that
unfortunately most students never
discover it helps you just sort out
what's going on here okay now this is
worth writing every nonzero number like
25 or more 36 37 or even negatives like
a negative 5 every nonzero number has
two square roots you can see why I had
to pull out 0 obviously because you were
so every nonzero number has two square
roots but we designate one of those
square roots as the most important one
the one that you're like okay this is
the one I usually mean I was frequently
right and we called that guy the
principal square root you're like okay
we've got you know more than one which
one's the one that you want to talk
about most frequently let's call that
one the principal one okay now you tell
me what is it that positive five one
like between five and negative five y is
five the more natural choice any
snitches
hmm well it's those three met square
roots why do we need square roots at all
yeah areas you can do the area of a
square or even like in terms of distance
right thinking of a square this is where
the Greeks worked it out they were like
well how far is it on the diagonals
right and you need to introduce squares
to do that good old Pythagoras yes now
if you're doing Pythagoras if you're
working out legs right there's what
there are no bad legs they're positive
right they are always positive so it
makes sense you like what I've got
choose one don't you just want to be the
important one the positive one makes
sense
good okay but it's not always so clear
cut the pivot important one a ton more
important one particularly in the
complex world every number every nonzero
number two square roots which one's the
most important one of this one it's not
as obvious okay so when you see a
question like this almost certainly
you'll sit freezing this way and you'll
see the plural there right in the same
way before I would say find the cube
root of a number find all the fourth
roots or fifth roots of a number you
guys found all the cube roots of
negative 8 just now and there were three
of them okay so to do this all we need
to remember is by definition right what
is a square root it's the number that if
you square it you get back that number
so how am I gonna work out the sky if
the square roots on this number are some
numbers then if that's the square root
then if you square that what should you
get back negative a plus 6i
now to proceed I'm going to take
advantage of the fact that I know that I
can write a couple excel Barozzi that
that shows it's just one number but I
can also write it as a separate bits
right as the real bit and the imaginary
bit right so I can write this as a plus
B I squared right this is I'm just
separating that so it's a little easier
to write okay equals maybe a plus C time
now what's wonderful about this is this
has turned this into a problem that I
know how to do that on the left hand
side is a multiplication problem right I
can do this so this is going to be this
this is just like a regular a plus B
squared right so there's going to be an
ace way but there's not going to be 2a
be in the middle is there what's going
to be in the middle to be all right
and normally I'd have a plus B squared
on the end but I don't have a plus B
squared on the end anymore do I
I have a good ok and Kumi here and we've
done this in quadratic expressions as
well is that now if you have a look at
the left hand side and you have a look
at the right hand side these things
allegedly are equal to each other right
well the left hand side has a real part
you see that those parts are real the a
squared minus B squared that has to be
real as their eyes are anything and the
right hand side also has a real bit
right in exactly the same way the left
hand side has an imaginary bit and the
right hand side has an imaginary and we
establish these are like oil and water
if you got some amount of oil water here
that's the same as the amount of oil in
water over there the oils must be the
same
the waters must be the same okay so even
on just a simple number I have
unwittingly created some simultaneous
equations right I'm going to say
comparing the real and imaginary parts
or the components right you have a look
on the left hand side and the real part
is a squared minus B squared
yeah
on the right hand side compare it to the
same bit it should be yeah that's that's
the real part so this is the first of my
son Tennessee patients right I've got
two unknowns a and B so I'd better have
two simultaneous equations you knew that
right if you are two unknowns you have
two equations three unknowns three
equations I'll help you if you have four
unknowns okay so yeah I'm gonna compare
the imaginary parts no no right I could
say to a VI equals six I that would be
true but but I don't need the lies
anymore right it's the A's and the B's
I'm trying to work with so what I'm
going to say is soon a B is equal to six
now I could designate that as equation 2
but I might as well do a little bit of
work with this so that I can actually
you know solve is um you've got two
methods for solving some tunes equations
what are though the elimination of and
substitution which one's going to be
useful here substitution so I'm going to
rewrite this so I can eliminate one of
the variables I'm gonna get rid of this
so if I make me the subject over here
the right hand side will be six on to a
which is three on there are you okay
with that yeah so now and that's what
I'm gonna call equation two okay now
this is fairly straightforward I'm now
going to substitute two into one
okay so that gives you this awkward
looking things a square takeaway what
three on a or squared yes which is nine
on a square yeah
that's equal to negative eight let's
continue right I want to solve this they
want to find out what a is what would
you let me to do with it there's a
couple different things that I could do
that they will all work probably the
quickest way is to multiply through by a
square okay now that might seem awkward
you're like oh no oh no I don't want I
don't want a quartic but that's okay
even though it's a quarter it's an
equation that's reduce
right so I can just write that and as a
four before plus eight a squared minus
nine in fact I can straight away
factorize this in terms of a squares
agree with that can you give you the
pair of numbers that adds to eight want
to play Sudoku plus 9 and negative one
so I'm gonna go a squared plus nine a
squared minus one equals zero now you
know all this fancy stuff about complex
factorization now so it might be
tempting to say ah-ha I can bring eyes
in here but think back think back the a
and the B are of these two things right
a sub real number right it has to be I
mean that's the real part right so
therefore one of these doesn't give you
solutions which one this one doesn't
give you solutions right because a has
to be a real number so I'm gonna say a
squared minus one equals zero only right
since this is a bit of a fancy way to
say it you could say a is a real number
but this is just some notation that says
the same thing faster that's a that is
an epsilon I'll explain set notation
later if you're curious but that's just
another way of saying a is a real number
so there's no real number you can square
add it tonight if you get zero so that
gives you those solutions all right so
what's a plus or minus one remember
we're solving an equation not evaluating
expression okay now that's a relief
isn't it why is it a relief that I have
two ounces because every nonzero number
has two square roots I've been gets you
now use you okay so therefore an is
negative one or a equals one but of
course every value of a will give you a
value of B right so the negative value B
is going to be equal to and in this case
B is just going to be three so now I
have sold my simultaneous equations why
was i solving simultaneous equations
again to find the values that would go
into my square roots right
so therefore Z is equal to there's a
positive 1 1 plus 3i and then there's a
negative 1 negative 1 minus 3r I've
depending on the number this is you know
they didn't have to be on positive or
negative if they could have been a
mismatch I can obviously write this as a
single number by taking advantage of the
plus/minus notation and there are my two
square roots I've done ok if you want to
you can contain yourself to actually
prove that this is the case by taking 1
plus 3i or taking negative 1 minus 3i
and then squaring it and you will see
you get negative a plus 6i back ok